you
so one of the questions I get asked all
the time is when you're out in public or
in your the real world when you're
having dinner with friends and you're
meeting your neighbors or relatives what
do you do if evolution comes up as a
topic of conversation or somebody says I
don't believe in evolution or I don't
think they should teach it in the
schools or it's just a theory
well we're in your right up front this
is a really good way to Elliott people
and get them upset with you but I think
there are much better ways to handle
disagreement and one of the first things
that I try to do when someone brings
that point of view up is politely
indicate that I disagree with them so
they understand what's going to follow
but then I try to do something that I
think all of you at this stage in your
careers can do very effectively and that
is what I'm not how science works
there's a stereotype out in the real
world there's a stereotype that science
is kind of like a closed community real
tight-knit fraternity or sorority we're
getting ahead depends on doing exactly
what your superiors want and always
cowering up to the big people the
National Academy people department chair
stuff like that the reality as I'm sure
all of you know is that science works in
an entirely different way the worst
thing anybody could hope for embarking
on a research project are results that
simply confirm existing ideas that's
boring what we all lay awake at night
dreaming about is the revolutionary
discovery the one that's going to upset
the applecart the one that's going to
destroy the common theory because that's
how you can make your reputation nobody
ever got famous by confirming other
ideas they got famous by coming up with
revolutionary results and hatching new
ideas of their own emphasized that
that's how science works the same
dynamic trust me
works in the field of evolutionary
biology at the genetics and the
molecular level the way in which people
get ahead is by testing by looking by
probing the theory any theory for
weaknesses and that counts as evolution
as well that counts in evolution as well
and what I first try to do is let people
know that science is contentious that
the very dynamic of science the
competitive nature of science guarantees
that if evolution was a uniquely weak or
shaky theory with no evidence behind it
people be standing in line scientists
standing a line to knock it off its
pedestal they're not I can't think of a
single theory in the life sciences that
has been tested and probed more
thoroughly than evolution it's a hundred
and fifty two years after the
publication of the Origin of Species and
it's still standing that's a darn good
theory second point that I try to make
is what a theory in science means to an
average person theory is just a guess or
a hunch
like I have a theory as to why the San
Francisco Giants won the pennant last
year or I have a theory as to why this
particular politicians ideas are good or
bad or indifferent it's not what we mean
by theory in science many people think
that fact is something you're certain
about in theory something shaky the
reality is that theory is a higher level
of understanding than fact and here's
the reason why
facts are simply repeatable isolated
observations I drop this ball it falls
down Sun comes up in the morning the
wavelength of light visible light is the
following these are all facts what
theories do is to take collections of
isolated facts and put them together
into a single explanatory framework for
example the theory the atomic theory of
matter is a theory that literally takes
hundreds of thousands of facts
observations about the nature of matter
and ties them all together into an
explanatory theory none of us in
education ever explained that expects a
course in atomic theory ten years from
now to be called of course in atomic
facts be as if atoms were something we
weren't sure about theories in science
never become facts theories in science
explain facts and the reality is but
although people raised a lot of
arguments against evolution there isn't
a single experimental factor observation
that has appeared in the last 150 years
that contradicts the broad outlines of
the theory of evolution then the last
thing I try to do is really very simple
and that is to say
science is an enterprise in which we try
to find out how the natural world works
it's not an enterprise that takes on
religion in a hostile way in fact many
of the greatest scientists in all
history have in fact been deeply
religious and we can start with Galileo
and Newton but in more recent times
gregor mendel the founder of the modern
science of genetics he was a priest as
it turns out theodosius dobzhansky i
know it's a big name but he's probably
the greatest evolutionary geneticist of
the 20th century he was a devout person
as well Francis Collins terrific cell
and molecular biologist who heads the
National Institutes of Health as an
evangelical Christian all of the people
that I just mentioned the recent people
are in fact strong supporters and
contributors to the science of evolution
now people can look at evolution and
draw a variety of conclusions as to how
it fits the religious faith but
evolutionary science itself like all of
science really is neutral on issues of
religion there are wastes as understand
evolution within a religious context and
I've actually written about those in a
couple of books and many articles and
other scientists have to and finally and
here's the most important thing when
someone expresses disagreement with you
on a point this fundamental I think what
you have to do is engage them and rather
than argue with him and by engage I mean
engage them as you would a colleague if
you and your colleague are working on
the same problem and you have slightly
different ideas about it what do you do
do you call each other names well maybe
in some cases in some fields you do but
what you do ideally is you lay out your
data you show each other your chell's
your sequences your atomic level
structures and from this airing of data
the other person begins to see that
you're a person of goodwill that you're
just interested in solving the same
problem that they are I have found that
technique in effect trying to take
people in to the scientific community
saying well let me show you why we think
this is so to be enormous ly effective
now I'll guarantee you you're not going
to be familiar with every argument that
comes out against the theory of
evolution some of your colleagues well
you might want to run though
arguments down you might want to go to
websites to try to find answers to these
arguments there's a really good website
called talk origins t ALK ori GI n s
talk origins calm in which all of the
anti evolution arguments that i've ever
heard of are answered in a very
definitive way so there are resources
out there for you but i think the most
important thing that any of us can do as
a scientist or as an apprentice
scientist is to let people know why we
went into science it wasn't because we
have a secular humanist axe to grind
it's not because we want to destroy god
it's because we really really want to
understand how the world works and when
people see that sincere motivation when
they see the twinkle in your eye you're
going to win them over they might be a
little baffled by some of the science
but once they see as i say that gleam in
your eye the the glint the excitement of
scientific discovery they're gonna drop
their suspicions of science and they're
gonna appreciate you as just another
person working in this great enterprise
lot's of luck with that
you